[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Alex is
in Norfolk Virginia hi Alex how are
you hi Dave I'm doing good how about you
better than I deserve what's
up uh so last night my wife turned to me
before bed and told me that she didn't
feel satisfied at work anymore and that
it it was causing her too much stress
and it just wasn't what she expected
when she joined the the job she works as
a a social
worker um while she's waiting to save up
to go into her master's so she can
become a clinical
psychologist um she moved here about
three years ago when uh we came here to
Virginia and she she's had plenty of
jobs since then but they've never lasted
longer than about six months before she
would either find a better job or uh
maybe they had a disagreement at work or
um she couldn't take the job
anymore and we're we're in the middle of
paying off the student loans from uh
from her psychology
degree and we just found out
that um my wife is pregnant like a month
ago so congratulations kind of hitting
me all thank you it's all kind of
hitting me all at once I'm very excited
about the baby but I was very I was very
collected when she told me about it she
was surprised and I told her it's
because we're financially stable we're
on a plan I don't have to worry about
knowing if we're going to be able to
afford the baby or not because I know
that we can but if she's moving if she's
planning on moving to a different job
that it shakes my my um my structure I
guess guess like it it shakes my rock I
don't have I don't I know that we can
get by on my income but get by with a
baby I make I'm in the Navy I make
uh I I
make 40 4,200 a month okay $50,000 a
year what does she make she
makes 23 a month okay $330,000 a year
okay
yep and we put 3,000 towards her debt
every month how much student loan debt
is uh
57 that's what it was last month
57,000 yes
oh yeah is that y'all's only debt
Alex yes we thought it was a lot less
than that until she graduated and we
looked at the numbers and it was twice
that twice of what you thought okay yeah
exactly uh what do you think not to like
psychoanalyze her but what what's the
with the job changes that are pretty
consistent with her what what do you
think the what do you think the thing is
about
that so her the reoccurring thing is she
doesn't Find meaning in her work when
she works somewhere that she finds
meaning at then she she never complains
about it and she hasn't complained about
this job for she's been there six months
now she hasn't complained about it until
the last um two months she she would she
started mentioning that she was tired of
training she's been training on the
computer ever since she got to the job
and every time they give her opportunity
to come forth and like do something
that's actually deals with social work
um she like trips or fumbles or doesn't
get something right and uh then somebody
gets upset with her she's got some rude
co-workers and then and she I think she
just can't handle it and she brought up
that um a lady called her that was
supposed to have called her a month ago
so that they could fix something but
then they now they couldn't fix it
because she didn't call when she was
supposed to and she got cussed out of
the phone and she wanted the job so she
could help people and she doesn't feel
like she's helping people she feels like
people are getting angry at her for
trying to
help okay how old is
she uh 20
three okay um what what what what can we
do to
help um I just I I want to know I I want
her to be happy in her work I don't I I
love listening to the Ken Coleman show
and I believe in like working at
something that you feel passionate about
and I want her to feel passionate about
what she does but I I'm scared because
so much is going on right now now and
she wants to make this Choice MH I want
to back her in whatever she wants but I
want to make sure that we're doing the
right
thing
yeah okay um there's two reasons that we
work one is to self-actualize and have
purpose and meaning in our work and do
work that matters and that certainly
needs to be the long-term goal all right
the second reason we work is we're
grown-ups and we have to feed our family
and you suck it up and put a callous on
your hand and you do the
work that's the two reasons you work now
here's the point what Ken Coleman is
telling people and what we tell people
here and have for 30 years is uh you
don't suck it up for 38 years you suck
it up for 38 months but she has never
once sucked it up she has never once
stiffened her backbone and walked
through a tough time every time the wind
blows she goes out the door that's who
you've described to us for the past few
minutes and so she has a baby on the way
and $57,000 in debt this is when you
suck it up if somebody's mean to you oh
well work welcome to the world deal with
it suck it up she has a she has a um she
has some problems with anxiety and she
wants to be a
psychologist yes sir okay okay we're
going to have to do
something she's going to have to at 23
years old she's going to have to develop
some toughness to be able to be a mommy
and to be a grownup and uh I'm not
saying anxiety is not real and I'm not
saying just pretend like you're not
anxious that's not the point if she
needs to see a counselor fine let's see
a counselor but but this idea that every
time it gets rough at work we quit
you're never going to keep a job in your
whole life I own this place and some
days I hate
it and I can do anything I want to do
but I do it anyway and Alex I think the
and I think the hard thing what you're
going to have to discover is you can't
control her as much as you want it for
her she has to want it herself and her
own journey of understanding herself and
why she is the way she is why we all are
right we all have to get to that point
where we're like okay what what has
caused me to have these patterns in my
life the wakeup call has to come from
her it can't come from you wanting her
to have it and that's going to be a
tough position that you're in Alex
you're calling the show for her right
let me ask you something she got
brothers and
sisters no she's an only child I thought
so okay and so she's her daddy's low
princess isn't she oh no she had U dad
problems oh okay so he he left he left
the picture halfway through okay all
right um cuz this uh it it sounds like
that um it's a lot of hurt she has a lot
she's functioning out of a lot a lot oft
and a lot of when she feels rejection
she bounces Alex probably from what you
just told us in the last 30 seconds from
her story I mean there's a lot of her
story she has to become aware of for her
to heal and become a whole person yeah
and not to bounce so I so part of me is
like I understand why she's doing it but
it's doesn't make it okay and so it puts
you in a tough position and so you're
going to have to sit down and have a and
you guys have to lay out these numbers
and just say hey for the next nine
months because when you have a baby
depending on what you want to do like we
have to be in this we have to we have to
figure out a way to pay down this debt
so that we're not drowning financially
and you need to be and I want and I want
you as your husband I'm seeing this
longterm I want you to be yes I want her
to be longterm I want her to be in
something she loves and where she's
helping people and where she's not
having to deal with toxic work
co-workers I don't I don't blame her for
that long term I want her to be there
but short term we got to be a grown-up
got a baby to baby to feed we got debt
to pay off and um and we probably do
need to get to the bottom of from a
psychological standpoint why we're
studying psychology and get into this